so today i'm going to talk about the
potential complications of having your
gallbladder removed there's definitely a
train of thought where we don't really
need our gallbladder so there's not
going to be any complications
but over 700 000
surgeries are done every single year and
40%
of the people who had their gallbladder
removed have complications so
i'm going to be talking about that the
medical term for this is
post cholecystectomy syndrome so before
i go into the symptoms i want to talk
about
why someone would experience those
symptoms it really has to do with
bile so bile is made by your liver
and bile drains down through a tube or a
duct
and it gets stored in the gallbladder
when you eat you need less
of the bile to digest food because it's
very concentrated
so without a gallbladder all you have
now is the tube
from your liver to the small intestines
and it trickles
but it's not concentrated so typically
the complications from not having a
gallbladder
have to do with a lack of bile
but there's exceptions to that sometimes
there's a situation where we have too
much bowel going into the small
intestine
in which case you have to take a certain
medication to
block the production of bile so that's a
different situation
what i want to talk about is the
symptoms that occur with not enough
bile now a good analogy to help you
understand what bile is
it is soap or a detergent
okay now detergent is very interesting
because
it is both water soluble
and fat soluble in other words you can
put it on fat
like greasy hands and rub it all around
and it will break down the fat and so
it's more water soluble so you can wash
your hands and
it can actually go down the drain right
so this
is oil and this is detergent so i'll
show you what happens
as an analogy to what happens when you
release bile so we're going to take this
detergent
and we're going to pour it into the oil
now at the molecular structure of a
detergent
you have one part that loves water and
one part that loves
oil or lipids or fat so
when i pour this into the oil
okay
put a little bit in there
and then i seal it up
like this okay so now just keep watching
so as you can see the detergent
broke down the oil or fat into smaller
particles
and that's what bile does so it's
another word for that is emulsification
okay
so you can see it's in a state now where
you could literally pour this down the
drain
and it won't clog anything because now
it's more water-soluble
your bile will break down fat into small
particles to allow the pancreas to
release
an enzyme called lipase and to make it
easy to digest that to even a smaller
particle
where you can absorb it in your
intestine so
if you are deficient in bile salts
you're going to have a difficulty
digesting fats so you may experience
bloating indigestion gas
burping okay so that's number one number
two constipation
one of the functions of bile
is to help lubricate the colon and
without bile
you may have constipation but if you
have too much bile because maybe there's
a
the duct is too large or the opening is
too large
you can get the opposite diarrhea if you
have diarrhea you don't want to
take more bile okay even as a supplement
because that's going to make it worse
okay we mentioned gas bloating even
stomach
pain okay you can even experience
your skin becoming more yellow or your
eyes becoming yellow that's
jaundice one of the purposes of the bile
is to take the byproduct of red blood
cells
which is bilirubin and help you
eliminate it through the body
so if there's some type of blockage
going on in the liver
where you're getting a backup of
bilirubin that can come out through the
skin
and create this situation right here and
usually what this means is that you need
more bile to help
remove the obstruction and allow the
drainage
bile will actually stimulate your own
release or flow of bile through the
ducts
especially if there's sludge or a
gallstone sitting in there because
bile will help to dissolve it one of the
causes of
a gallstone is concentrated cholesterol
because there's not enough bile
to keep it broken down all right
hypothyroidism your body has
certain enzymes that convert t4
the inactive version of the thyroid
hormone to t3 the active
form of the thyroid hormone well guess
what
bile triggers that conversion so without
enough bile
it can create hypothyroid symptoms
number nine your right shoulder is very
very tight
if there's congestion or some type of
blockage
of the ducts from your liver so you
can't release the bile it backs up and
causes pressure irritation
and it can create referral pain in your
right shoulder up to your neck
even headaches on this side it can also
leave you with a tightness underneath
your right rib cage
the solution is to take some purified
bile salts
because it will help remove the
obstruction and open the flow so you
have
less pressure in that area dry skin dry
eyes
this is a vitamin a deficiency
because bile helps you break down and
absorb
vitamin a d e or k
a deficiency of bile could give you
symptoms of vitamin a
e d or k and then we have
vision problems a certain percent of the
population
notice that their eyes are blurry after
they have their gallbladder removed
or they have vision issues or they may
have glaucoma
or a problem even with cataracts you
need
vitamin a to prevent those conditions
and so without enough vitamin a
you may have a difficult time seeing
especially in the dark at night
and that lack of vitamin a can create a
whole series of issues
so for all of these complications
purified bile salts you can take
one or two after a meal if you want to
see some quick results sometimes if you
have like
right shoulder pain or tightness
underneath the right rib cage you can
take one
on an empty stomach and take another one
on an empty stomach later in the day
and that will give your liver a chance
to drain properly and get rid of that
sensation
all right thanks for watching
hey we're back with another amazing
recipe no grains
no sugar totally keto there's no
suffering in keto
absolutely not karen and it's an immune
system builder
absolutely you have to check this out i
think you should hurry up
watch the recipe and make it yourself
it's just so easy to be keto
but is it simple it's super simple we
hope you enjoy
making it as much as we are enjoying
eating it